Bitcoin Creator Satoshi Nakamoto could
be unmasked at Florida trial so a lot of
people are talking about the
specifically the cryptocurrency
community
um so the family of a deceased man is
soon his former business partner over
control of their Partnerships Assets in
this case the asset in question uh our
cachet of about 1 million Bitcoins
equivalent to about 64 to 70 billion
dollars today belonging to bitcoin's
Creator and pseudonym Satoshi Nakamoto
the family of the dead man says he and
his business partner together were
Nakamoto and thus the family is entitled
to half the fortune this is what a
Florida jury will try to tackle the
family of David Kleinman is suing his
former business partner 52 year old 51
year old Australian programmer living in
London named Craig Wright Wright has
been arguing since 2016 that he created
bitcoin claim dismissed by most in
Bitcoin Community climbing's Family
argues that the two worked on and mined
Bitcoin together entitled climate's
family to a half a million Bitcoins by
the way very interesting angle to get
Satoshi to come out right I actually
like the angle to force the guy to come
out you know this story is really
fascinating and you know there's so much
money involved I'm surprised somebody
has been killed yet right because this
goes back to 2008 somebody is holding on
to that private key right someone has it
you think maybe they're not coming off
for that reason you think that's why the
person doesn't want others to know I
think this thing could be a movie it
could be a deadline episode or a
dateline episode or something now I do
know the one person on the planet that
could find the true identity here we go
of Sakamoto Nakamoto Sakamoto yeah
that's a perfect drink but it's Bernie
Sanders because he'll want that tax
money right so he can go find that
person go get the tax money out he can
shame him on Twitter video see on the
case right I believe that he could
actually find it but this really is a
fascinating story who leaves that that
much money out there unless they're very
very patient right and and this whole
thing with the Florida only in Florida
right could you find this it's one of
those only in Florida
um it seems like a stretch but the Deep
this this is a fast if they had core TV
I'd be watching this trial on TV right
now I really would so I think nothing's
gonna happen I don't think I mean you
interviewed Craig Wright do you think
he's satosha Nakamoto I don't know I I
lean towards no but I don't know but I I
there's a lot of people in the community
there's some that say Craig Wright
there's a lot that say Adam back there's
a lot you know there's different names
that come up on who could be Satoshi
Nakamoto I know who Robert in the office
thinks it is he thinks it's a CIA thinks
it's the government that's behind it the
government designed this is what he's
thinking and the other thing I think as
well with this is Robert a big thing a
big thing yeah we went to the moon in
1920 gentlemen so it's uh it's it's
Robert that's a bright guy to say
something like that it's not like
Robert's not a bright guy no no no no no
not at all uh the only the big thing
here for me is that uh neither one of
them have found have the keys to the to
the to the wallet so without that you're
screwed the private key yes and without
that you can't even get a hold exactly
so so why would if you're if if Craig
Wright is him and he claims to be him
why wouldn't he just reveal it it's like
one thing you have to do to prove it
well BBC did a story with him I think it
was BBC did a story with them getting
him ready to reveal the key and he was
supposed and he couldn't do it I don't
know if you've seen the video I haven't
seen that video if you've not seen it
it's very interesting but it's still I'm
gonna show the world that I'm the guy
and it's like oh it's not working I
forgot I you know so it's kind of a
little bit awkward exactly if you listen
to this folks who do you think
especially those you guys that follow
crypto who do you think Satoshi Nakamoto
is go ahead Tom
you know
I think things hide in plain sight and
no one has come out to counter these
guys and so as odd as it sounds and the
missing key sometimes the simplest
explanations like when big complicated
crimes you have all the Talking Heads
talking about crimes for weeks and weeks
and weeks like the missing girl and then
the guy found in the swamp right it ends
up being very simple it's always that
guy you know nobody don't say that but
it's a simpler story than we all
weave it into being when we're
overthinking it I
I tend to lean that it's These Guys
these guys run a partnership and they
create it because it's usually the
simple answer so you do think this is
the I'm leaning this way I'm leaning
this way saying you know what this is
very plausible that these two guys
created it these two guys created the
the the you know the the secret pirate
in the back you know flying the flag
against fiat currency and you know okay
question for you what's what's their
rationale for not cashing in on any of
it
foreign
it's like why why wouldn't one of them
Take the Money and Run I mean in this
case though if they were partners and
Craig Wright proved to have it then he'd
have to pay look there's very
interesting things with law you send me
a story yesterday about Vanessa Brian
but what happened where she was maybe
you tell the story what happened there
well she's suing L.A County Sheriff's
Department because they took photos of
the of the crash scene when Kobe died
they looked at him they circulated them
she's suing them saying that it has cost
her some serious traumatic damage right
so now the county wants access to her
records of any psychological exams or
therapy sessions so they can see if it
actually did cause that or if she's just
saying that so that's interesting so so
that's the part about law
that if you file a lawsuit
the person can come and ask specific
questions to validate your point that it
affected you right and in this case when
this guy's coming out saying Satoshi is
my 50 50 partner
if he doesn't come out I mean law law
can almost Force this guy to come out so
he's either going to be sitting there
saying look you know I don't want to
come out and give up half of 74 billion
dollars or he's going to come out and
say it's me and then how is this going
to change Adam back said in an interview
about why it's not a good idea for so I
told you to come out and why it's better
for the world not to know yeah the way
he explained it was it's better to not
see the one person as an expert because
every time something happens with that
currency they're going to go to so what
do you think since you started this what
do you think since you started it says I
don't think that's a good idea I think
we need to leave it alone
as just a currency without a Founder to
that currency that's their view on
bitcoin I think a big thing about that
too is that it's better to not have
somebody who's behind it because then
it's truly decentralized like if it's if
it's a certain person then that's
another argument you don't know how much
he owns and if that could then totally
tank the market or not so I think a big
thing there is just a matter of having
it decentralized to where we don't know
and that's part of the mystery of of
which is a good thing because that gives
it a little bit trust it's more like
almost spiritual or religious where it's
like I believe in it I don't know who
what why but that's kind of what we're
thinking I was interviewed by Natalie
Brunell yesterday who's a a Bitcoin
expert and a finance expert kind of like
a pompliano type of person not crypto
she made it very specific she's Bitcoin
uh and she's a uh uh what do you call it
a finance expert and she had a story
that went live on Twitter uh that went
viral on Twitter like a million views or
two million views on Fox Business she
was talking about how the economy right
now is favoring Bitcoin you saw what
shamat said just couple days ago the
fact that people were laughing at me
when Bitcoin was 200 and I told them
this thing's going to go to the roof and
you guys didn't buy into it and now it's
60 some thousand dollars and so it's
going to go to 100 000. it's going to go
to 150 it's going to go to 200 000 it's
a matter of time before that happens
it's gonna happen in a year two years
three years I don't know but the
argument of where they are is making
more and more and more sense on the
ethereum side what's starting to make
more sense is the fact that all nfts are
being purchased through ethereum
ethereum which means those who were not
for ethereum if nft takes off that means
ethereum takes off so the biggest
question right now for an investor if I
were to ask a question and I you know
both sides of the argument they give me
different argument here's here's the
argument what's ethereum today what is
the word today do you know what the
numbers are now in ethereum I was just
popping that up I lifted my pronouns
what is ethereum right now I know over
the coinbase and see the uh uh uh it's
at 4
318 okay so ethereum is at 43.18 okay
and Bitcoin is at sixty thousand seven
thirty two right here's the question you
gotta ask yourself what is more likely
of happening is it more likely for
ethereum to go from 4300 to 12 000 or is
it more likely for Bitcoin to go from
sixty thousand to two hundred thousand
what's more likely can I I say they're
equally likely exactly right okay you're
saying equally yeah so that's what the
Bitcoin folks will say that it's equally
likely likely but the nft folks will
tell you ethereum is going to catch up
to bitcoin that's the debate right now
between the two yeah this is the law of
small stocks right you come into a stock
at five you think you go to 15. now you
just tripled your money whereas you go
into you know Amazon or Apple at 250
it's got to get the 600. so it's you
know it's the law of small stocks here
it's a really good point there because
you've got you know wearable and open C
really controlling like 80 percent of
the nft market or something like that I
mean they are the Giants in the room and
it's all ethereum and you know with um
and what's the leading mask the the
leading wallet mask okay so check this
out we got 324 likes right now and we
got 95 dislikes folks if you're more
leaning towards Bitcoin
tripling before ethereum put thumbs up
if you're more for ethereum tripling
before Bitcoin put thumbs down I'm
curious because I the it is becoming
like a religion it's so interesting
watching the Bitcoin and the ethereum
community can I say something about this
story I think it is utterly fascinating
that we don't know the creator of
Bitcoin because if you are involved in
that world where you are creating a
currency you're in the finance world
you're interested in making money all
right you're driven by that and this is
just sitting here no one knows either
the person's dead right or what could
possibly be the motivation for us not
knowing who this is and what happens
when this is 740 billion or a 200
billion or something like that it's 74
billion right now if we were talking
about this story at the beginning of the
year it would have been way less than
that but that's a lot of money sitting
on the table that's not going to be the
first lawsuit and I just think this is a
fascinating mystery so you think it's a
matter of time it's a matter of time
before it comes out I think maybe
that maybe not so much the identity of a
single person but maybe more of how this
was created and and then we'll learn
that it isn't one person possibly
by the way it's it's more people voting
for Bitcoin tripling than ethereum yeah
two to one is what the numbers are
looking like right now so there's a lot
of Bitcoin people then ethereum people
especially maybe at least on this
podcast uh real Diaz thank you for the
20 bucks somebody uh they just gave
fifty dollars uh said the following
which is quite interesting he said
convinced the government created bitcoin
the perfect tool for moving off the
books cash also guaranteed to have
built-in totally disagree with that
totally disagree tell me why because
it's too hard for a government employee
to keep a secret I could see uh oh it's
not it's not a government employee
though this is like a a uh a yeah but a
government employee would know of the
secret
if you go if you go from the defense
budget where I mean they can't even keep
track of their money they don't know
what goes where everyone who has what
and who has access to what and who knows
about what so if anything in the
government it's some sort of military
budget that's been off the books
blacklisted that where it's been then
there's a I mean look they're looking to
change the military some former military
member that was involved this would talk
I think when you create something that
potentially becomes this big enough
people know about it where someone is
going to say something if it's a
government entity so if you enjoy this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]